write your sad times in the sand
write your good times in stone
[Music]
both optimists and pessimists contribute
to society
The Optimist invents the airplane
the pessimist the parachute
beware of false knowledge
it is more dangerous than ignorance
learn how to do it better and listen to
these quotes by George Bernard Shaw
the Liar's punishment is not in the
least that he has not believed
but that he cannot believe anyone else
our lives are shaped not as much by our
experiences as by our expectations
a life spent making mistakes is not only
more honorable
but more useful than a life spent doing
nothing
don't wait for the right opportunity
create it
[Music]
we are made wise not by the recollection
of our past
but by the responsibility for our future
[Music]
do not do unto others as you would that
they should do unto you
their tastes may not be the same
[Music]
Never Wrestle with pigs you both get
dirty and the pig likes it
people who say it cannot be done should
not interrupt those who are doing it
life isn't about finding yourself
life is about creating yourself
[Music]
it is not enough to know what is good
you must be able to do it
the truth is the one thing that nobody
will believe
he who can does
he who cannot teaches
[Music]
after all
the wrong road always leads somewhere
we learn from experience that men never
learn anything from experience
[Music]
progress is impossible without change
[Music]
bravery doesn't get worse because it's a
little hard
[Music]
wisdom is wasted on the old
and youth is wasted on the young
[Music]
a woman always chooses the man
who chose a different woman
[Music]
make it a rule never to give a child a
book you would not read yourself
for every complex problem there is a
simple and wrong solution
there is no other edifice constructed by
man as altruistic as a lighthouse
they were built only to serve
the things most people want to know
about are usually none of their business
a government that robs Peter to pay Paul
can always depend on the support of Paul
Liberty means responsibility
that is why most men dread it
[Music]
life is not meant to be easy
but take courage it can be delightful
[Music]
you see things you say why
but I dream of things that never were
and say why not
[Music]
the fact that a Believer is happier than
a skeptic is no more relevant than that
a drunk is happier than a sober
[Music]
better keep yourself clean and bright
you are the window through which you
must see the world
those who cannot change their minds
cannot change anything
newspaper
a device unable to distinguish between a
bicycle accident and the collapse of
civilization
all men are the same in front of the
woman they admire
[Music]
there is no love more sincere than the
love of food
my way of joking is to tell the truth
It's the funniest joke in the world
[Music]
the only time one's education is
interrupted was when they were in school
[Music]
the single biggest problem in
communication
is the illusion that it has taken place
The Secret of being miserable is to have
the Leisure to bother about whether you
are happy or not
[Music]
criminals do not die by the hands of the
law they die by the hands of other men
why should we take advice on sex from
the Pope
if he knows anything about it he
shouldn't
success does not consist in never making
mistakes
but in never making the same one a
second time
[Music]
patriotism is fundamentally
a conviction that a particular country
is the best in the world
because you were born in it
[Music]
there are two tragedies in life
one is to lose your heart's desire
the other is to gain it
he knows nothing and thinks he knows
everything
that points clearly to a political
career
[Music]
you use a glass mirror to see your face
you use works of art to see your soul
a pessimist is a man who thinks
everybody is as nasty as himself
and hates them for it
if there were 20 ways of telling the
truth and only one way of telling a lie
the government would find it out
it's in the nature of governments to
tell lies
hatred is the coward's revenge for being
intimidated
[Music]
you don't stop laughing when you grow
old
you grow old when you stop laughing
[Music]
when a thing is funny search it
carefully for a hidden truth
[Music]
all great truths begin as blasphemies
liquor is the chloroform which enables
the poor man to endure the painful
operation of living
the most tragic thing in the world is a
man of Genius
who was not a man of Honor
you'll never have a quiet World till you
knock the patriotism out of the human
race
the moment we want to believe something
we suddenly see all the arguments for it
and becomes blind to the arguments
against it
[Music]
doing what needs to be done may not make
you happy
but it will make you great
[Music]
would the world ever have been made if
its maker had been afraid of making
trouble
alcohol is the anesthesia by which we
endure the operation of life
[Music]
The Savage bows down to Idols of wood
and Stone
the Civilized man to Idols of flesh and
blood
if it's hard for you to make friends
soon you'll realize that they're not
always necessary
[Music]
no doubt there are slavish women as well
as slavish men
and women like men
admire those that are stronger than
themselves
a woman always hates a man who loves her
with animal love
[Music]
no diet will remove all the fat from
your body because
the brain is entirely fat
without a brain you might look good
but all you could do
is run for public office
10 pounds is a lot of money
whoever gets them starts to live with
caution
which means the end of happiness
we have selected these quotes from Nobel
Laureate George Bernard Shaw his quotes
are steeped in politics religion and art
and we hope you enjoyed this video
thank you for watching it